good evening everyone I think we're
pretty much on quarter pass let's make a
start like to welcome everybody to
tonight's meeting of the planning
committee a my name is Danny Kendall
I'll be chairing tonight's meeting in
accordance with the rules and procedures
set out on the inside cover of your
agendas tonight before we get started if
I could just make members of the public
aware of the fact that the meeting is
being recorded so in the next day or so
if you want to review tonight's
proceedings you can do so by going to
the council's website
I could also remind members of the
public to make sure and I suppose
committee members as well to make sure
that your mobile phones are turned off
or at least to silent
that'll be fantastic as well before we
go to our first item can I ask people on
the top here to introduce themselves
please planning manager Amy flutes
planner Louise Coleman thank you before
we go further could I just get you to
explain you're rolling this is planning
manager please two members to clarify
any planning issues that arise and to
assist members decision taking I'm bound
by the Royal Town Planning Institute
code of Professional Conduct and of
course planning committee members are
not bound by any advice from officers or
by their recommendations
thank you Jeff it's wonderful thank you
so we move to our first item on the
agenda any apologies for absence please
thank you very much councillor Crump
right item two disclosure of interests
anybody councillor Perry thank you and
good evening chair just wanted to
highlight something I don't believe it's
a conflict of interest but the
application reference D is C n /z row 0
3 o 4 forward slash 1 8 the land joining
Chart Church farm court the company that
I work for two days a week have in the
past
being involved with some projects with
the applicant but to my knowledge we're
not involved but I just felt I ought to
raise that so as far as I'm concerned
I'm coming to the committee with an open
mind thank you any further disclosure of
interests nope
the minutes I understand have been
approved last meeting so we don't need
to deal with those so it takes us to our
first application tonight which is item
four found on page 11 of your agendas
right this is application reference 18 /
0 3 3 0 0 / ful and it's for hill farm
Stratford Road wouldn't Rowan Henry nod
and as for the construction of an
agricultural workers dwelling with
associated works to replace temporary
agricultural workers dwelling presenting
officer mrs. Amy flute over to you thank
you the application sites denoted by the
black dot is a parcel of land access of
the a3 400 the site is within an open
countryside location the application
site edged red is to the south
Stratford Canal is cited to the
northwestern the self Stratford Canal is
cited to the northwest and public
footpath SD 189 runs along with the
access tract the application site is
within the art and special landscape
area and is washed over by the West
Midlands Greenbelt
planning permission is sought for the
erection of an agricultural workers
dwelling with associated works which
would replace the on-site mobile home
for an agricultural worker granted under
a temporary permission the existing
mobile home can be seen to the south of
the access tract with the farm buildings
to the north the proposed dwelling would
be two stories with dormer windows on
the reef and would measure approximately
seven point six meters to the ridge
eight point three meters in depth and
fourteen point nine meters in length
including the projections the proposed
dwelling would be constructed from brick
tile with white aluminium windows and
painted hardwood doors looking at the
site in a southwesterly direction from
the access drive the existing mobile
home
can be seen in the distance the farm
buildings are situated to the south of
this building and they cannot be seen
the existing mobile home can now be seen
looking in an easterly direction and the
northern sights boundary can now be seen
so this image is looking down the access
track in an easterly direction towards
the a3 400 and farm buildings can now be
seen which are situated approximately 45
meters in a civilly direction from the
existing mobile home it is considered
that there is a functional need to live
on site and that the business is
financially sustainable and the proposed
rule were workers dwelling is considered
to accord with core strategy policy a
s10 and policy h1 of the NDP whilst the
proposal is considered inappropriate
development harmful to the openness of
the Greenbelt
it has been identified that there is an
essential need for a worker to live on
site resulting in very special
circumstances to outweigh the identified
Greenbelt harm to a quarter of course
strategy policy cs10 and the MPP F
Chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions and notes as details within
the committee report thank you thank you
Amy right let's go to our first speaker
so our first speaker tonight is a
councillor marking a call from wooden
one parish council hello sir like to
please take a seat
welcome right so you have three minutes
twenty seconds to help you out anyway if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end as well okay okay well the
additional information to show the need
for some agricultural accommodation it
doesn't doesn't demonstrate why this
cannot be provided by the various
properties already located on site the
parish council notes a history of
residential development and the removal
of previous long-standing agricultural
ties on this site which undermines the
argument
of this application there has been
previous applications to turn the barn
complex into residential dwellings
breach for agricultural tie and removal
property tie on a previous Chalet
bungalow the application doesn't
demonstrate why this need can't be met
by the existing properties the
additional information does demonstrate
that continuous 24-hour cover is only
required during the Lummi period other
occasions such as to provide medication
to sick animals will be ad hoc the
season 1 otherwise intermittent nature
of the requirement is precisely why
temporary accommodations such as it's
currently there could be an appropriate
solution due to its location in the
Greenbelt even if one accepts the
argument for the permanent dwelling
planners and parish council must still
consider the impact on its surroundings
when approving the design on that basis
the introduction of a large modern
4-bedroom 2 story family property into
this rural setting is inappropriate to
protect the conserve the Greenbelt a
smaller single-story design with perhaps
two bedrooms would be much more
appropriate and would still provide the
required accommodation the location of
the proposed site is away from existing
buildings residences which means that
the site and hill farm is getting quite
spread out last time I was in front of
this committee a few months ago we're
talking about Lucy's farm which is
across the road across the a 3,400 from
this application and as another local
farmer was refused development on that
site even though there's an existing
buildings that seems to contradictory to
approve this one if the committee is in
mind to Grant's application approach
council would ask that there is a
minimum period for the agricultural ty
of at least 10 years or longer
there's also question about the
community infrastructure let Levy
which should be payable but the
applicant has asked for exemption which
does question about what the property
will actually be useful very much
okay you have any questions you
mentioned that there wasn't mr. Cooney
just a justification for this question
the justification and the need for this
application yet the district council
employees consultants Kernan I think is
on page 14 in the agenda and they quite
nearly quite clearly say that the
proposal meets the test for permanent
dwelling
so I'll just obviously we've got the
consultants who we rely on over the
experts saying that there is the need
and you're saying as a as the local
parish council that there wasn't the
knee so I'll just wonder why you could
justify that please the consultants are
provided by they're actually the
capsules consultants but just question
whether sufficiently to justify the
developments in that property okay
that's fine are there any further
questions from the committee
yes councillor Dixon do you understand
that there are the residential
accommodations within the same ownership
there are I'm not sure about ownership
it's bit unclear as to who owns thank
you any further questions that case
counts Nicole thank you very much for
your time and we can move our next
speaker mr. David yeah
right I'm sorry you hid your sentence
questions okay I think we can I think we
can we can go with that that's okay
welcome then mr. Amma you have three
minutes as well
if you remain seated for any questions
at the end and I'll give you a warning
at 20 seconds if you need it yes
over to you Leanne I'm just going to
speak to you background about the farm
while it's fish my head I'd just like to
respond to some of the parish comments
as far as the tide bungalow the tide
chalet it's never been in the ownership
of may my family at all it was a totally
separate dwelling and had a cultural tie
we actually try actually wanted to buy
but it may over double the reserve price
and then there's always our moved it's
never had anything to do with us
whatsoever
I just wanted to clear that up and so a
little brief history I've been farming
on the farm for over 20 years I
inherited it 10 years ago from my late
father
at which time was the just after the
foot-and-mouth crisis so a lot of our
stock was wiped out with that so I took
the opportunity to restock James farming
Enterprise into a more rather than
producing beef and sheep for meat it was
more for breeding so we have a petty
Billings unheard a pedigree Texel sheep
herd that we then produce the lungs and
breeding animals to trim balls to sell
on to the farmers it just makes the
business a lot more less susceptible to
volatile market changes basically which
has worked and we've become more
successful over the last 10 years into
quite a good profitable farm in fact we
we're in the top 5% so now of
profitability our own farms we been in
the mobile home now for eight years
and we want to live there to run the
farm we have to be there for the lambing
for the carving for all the assistants
and one of the one of the perfect
examples is even now we've got a cow in
now is due to calf at the moment I've
got to get all get dressed to get in the
car drive down checker it's all fine
home back to bed if we know if we live
it on sides we can literally get up put
your well it's on Fitz can look over the
fence do if it's needed you can get on
with a lot you can get back and you can
live a normal life and we just want to
you know carry on farming there and we
go we have five children all together
and they're all very interested in the
farm and I just hope that we can carry
on these success for that hopefully
that'll carry the farm and that's pretty
much all I wanted to say to be honest
thank you any questions
councillor Perry do this the cycles of
your breeding in the and your different
rare breeds and types of animals yes do
they sort of run throughout the year or
just explain a little bit more about the
times that you you need to be getting up
yes at the moment we've got 550 breeding
ewes so they wheel a mean sorting in
batches but I sort of run overlap so we
land from December until until April
pretty much and then the cows we've got
and the man we've got sixty breeding
cows which we are hoping we've got a few
heifers which do carve all year round so
because they're quite they're called
highly figure they're very very you know
well bred so they you do have a lot more
involvement with with the carving so
because it's so pretty more teats it's
pretty much all year round and because
we're doing it most you know mostly
ourselves you
you've got to spread the work out across
the acres you can't cope at one time
okay cancer krump he mentioned that
breeding stock
yes so therefore I assume the lumps in
the car valuable therefore if he lost
one by not being there you would feel a
greater financial loss Oh certainly
certainly and we we just well we sold an
assault with cow and a pedigree livers
and cow with a bull calf last week for
four thousand seven hundred pounds about
a month ago
stony market the cows calves were making
between 800 and 1,200
it's a massive it is a massive
difference Thank You counsel Adam thank
you just a question in regard to the
other buildings on the site they
currently fully used and occupied or any
of those vacant you mean the farm
buildings yes yeah they walk they will
follow the stock or hay and that type of
thing is there's no we've got the mobile
home there but all the other buildings
are just barns with cows and sheep in
basically thank you right there no
further questions thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you
alright we now go to our board member
council Shenton
welcome counselor Shenton counselor
Richards can I just ask you to turn off
the microphone on your on that on this
that all right thank you
welcome counsel Shelton so five minutes
don't have to use all of it but if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end give you a warning at 30 seconds
over to you thank you good evening
members and officers the application is
for this born half story high farmhouse
type construction which would replace
the existing mobile site have know about
home on the site when the application
was submitted I wasn't a counselor and
my prepossessed I didn't make any
representations I understand the
concerns of the parish council and the
need to preserve the Greenbelt something
that they and I feel very passionately
though but there's also the need to
protect and help our farming community
it doesn't appear to be any suitable
living accommodation on site and in
reference to Lucy's farm that was a much
larger development and can't be compared
directly with this particular
application my view is that the the
planning application meets the NP FF
guide on the need for sustainable
development on the economic objective
paragraph it also appears to me to the
requirements of section 79 of the MTF F
which states that there we should avoid
the development of isolated towns in the
countryside unless there is an essential
need for a rural worker including those
taking majority control to live
permanently after all near their place
of work in the countryside section 83
appears to reinforce that as wrong mr.
Moore is committed to the local area and
economy because as well as providing
employment through the farming
he's instrumental in developing the
marina and diversifying on Hill Farm
that Don's going there's ongoing
construction there the applicants lived
in a mobile home
number of years and as such it seemed to
do on the faith to demonstrate the need
for an agricultural worker to live on
the farm itself the site itself is well
outside the built-up boundary of walking
rowing and whilst it's in the Greenbelt
and set so far back from the main road
along the track but it's not close
enough to any neighboring properties to
cause heavy major concerns indeed a
couple of the closest properties
actually are in support of the
application you'll see that there's
confirmation that the farm is viable and
in the life of the reports that suggests
that it would make sense to have a
dwelling located on the farm itself on
the core of the farm the character of
the design is such that any impact will
be mitigated by the one and a half story
type design and it fits within the
overall plot that's being used for the
temporary building there's an argument
perhaps that the current arrangement is
more of a blot on the landscape than the
proposed building and the new building
would add more in benefit to the
landscape than he takes away in terms of
openness of the Greenbelt we should
protect the openness of the land that
the harm if any is limited and the
greater benefit is derived in my opinion
from having an agricultural workers home
on site to deal with the issues as they
arise
indeed the campaign for rural England
appear to raise very little in the way
of an objection though it fits in with
policy a s-10 the core strategy and does
seem to fit in with policy age one of
the woman wearing neighbourhood plan
which states that new houses in the
countryside will be strictly controlled
and limited to dwellings for rural
workers which is brought this particular
application is about to recap on my
arguments for granting permission the
applicants currently living in a mobile
home on the site the planners appear to
be comfortable with the scale and design
no objections from neighbors the farm is
viable see fury don't appear to have any
great objections it's not at odds with
the objectives overall objective of the
MPF fair
the call strategy or the woman wearing
neighbourhood plan so my feeling is very
much that this application should be
granted with two conditions namely that
it should only be for that of an
agricultural worker as defined in the
Town and Country Planning Act and a
permission for the temporary mobile home
which is currently on there should be
rescinded within an appropriate time
after the completion of the build
once again I'd just like to stress that
I understand the position of the parish
council with regards to the effect on
the green belt but would ask the
committee to consider the special
circumstances and support the planners
recommendation and grant the application
Thank You Council gentlemen any
questions for our ward member thank you
very much
right lots of speakers out the way do we
have any points of clarification
councillor Richards thank you 13 sorry
should have probably put it in English
and second if I'm a chair is it's not
uncommon for us to put some form of
agricultural tie on as a condition I
don't see one in there is there one and
if there's not would it be prudent for
us to include more on applications like
this we would be looking to tie the
future obviously ownerships you
agricultural workers and it is within
the recommendations it's it's condition
five and it just says occupancy
thank you any other points of
clarification counsel parrot no
councillor Richards raise the point I
was going to read I'll just follow on
that we're all really briefly I mean
just remind me if we have the requiring
us to be tied to an agricultural worker
the parish council said they'd want it
to be for at least 10 years wouldn't it
would be a permanent eye and any
circumstances in the future why there
was a potential reason why that tie was
no longer required and they would the
documents would have to apply for
planning permission to us and then we
would assess whether or not it was
reasonable for the tide to be removed
and they would have to submit marketing
information and we would have to be
comfortable that the farm was no longer
viable so what they are thank you any
other points clarification are we done
should we go to the debate councillor
Richards so I'm gonna propose that we do
go ahead and grant this as set out in
our report I think the report is very
well reasoned and in particular the
evidence required through the currents
report provides me with sufficient
evidence that the tests are met Thank
You councillor para Thank You chair I I
feel very satisfied by what I've heard
this evening from the applicant I think
that has reinforced the professional
evidence that we've had because of the
need around the 12 months and I think
the ward member made an excellent case
in support of the application so I'd
like to second councillor Richards
proposal for granting application thank
you anybody else want to speak in the
debate on this
right let's go to the vote then shall we
we've got a proposer and a second door
that say that we grabbed the application
all those in favor please show thank you
very much that case the committee
resolves to grant application reference
18 / 0 3 3 0 0 / ful we move to our next
application is item 5 we found on page
23 of your agendas tonight right
application reference 18 / 0 2 2 4 4 /
ful and this is for the land rear of 225
a High Street Henley and Alden and is
for the demolition of an existing garage
and office and the construction of one
new dwelling presenting officer is Amy
flute again Amy if you already over to
you thank you chairman the application
sites donated by the black dot is a
garage with officer birth within the
garden area of 225 a High Street Henley
in Arden the site edge red has its own
access off Prince Harry's Road to the
east the application site is within
Henry and Arden's built-up area boundary
their conservation area and also there
are a number of listed buildings to the
west along the high street which are
colored in red planning permission is
sought for the erection of a dwelling in
place of the garage an aerial photo with
the site edge red shows the site in the
context of the existing built for the
proposal will demolish the existing
garage building and erected dwelling
which will be set further west of the
plot off Prince Harry's Road with offer
a parking it must be noted that 2 to 5 a
has separate offer a parking provision
of the high street the existing garage
building measures approximately eight
point four meters in width seven point
four meters in depth and six point four
meters to the ridge the design of the
proposed railing has been amended during
the course of the application the
proposed dwelling would be set on
slightly higher ground slightly higher
land level
measuring approximately seven point
seven meters in width fourteen point one
meters in depth and six point eight
meters to the reefs rich Gables would
front the highway and the dwelling would
be constructed from timber
render the proposed dwelling can be seen
in a street scene context with the
immediate properties to the application
site fronting Prince Harry's Road the
dwelling would have living space at
ground floor and free bed dreams at
first floor the existing garage office
is constructed from red brick tiles and
timber doors the gables do not front the
highway the rear of the garage has a
central dormer window and is set down
from the grass garden area of two to
five a high street this view is taken
from the rear garden of 225 a looking in
a southerly direction and shows a
dwelling surrounding Prince Harry's Road
and now looking in a northerly direction
this image is looking in a westerly
direction from the application site
towards the rear of 225 a High Street
the properties to the south of the
application site of Prince Harry's Road
vary in size style and design the
apartment block immediately south of the
application site can now be seen which
is set in a more easterly direction off
Prince Harry's Road on slightly higher
land level the next two images are
looking in a southerly direction from
Prince Harry's Road towards the
application site the site can now be
observed looking in a northerly
direction from Prince Harry's Road the
principal of a dwelling is acceptable in
this location and it is considered to
accord with core strategy policy CS 15
and CS 16 it is not considered that the
proposed proposed development would have
a detrimental impact on heritage assets
or the character of the street scene and
accords with call strategy policy CS 8
and zs9
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions and notes as detailed within
the committee report thank you thank you
Amy
right first speaker on this application
is councillor David Broadbent Henley an
ardent parish council
welcome counselor so the same rules
apply you have three minutes if you'd
remain seated for any questions at the
end and I'll give you a warning last 30
seconds okay
this property belongs to the current
board member Matt Jennings the jpc has
no objection to the erection of a new
building on this site and we believe our
concerns regarding parking and vehicles
has been addressed however the design of
the building does not complement the
street scene of Prince Harry Road or
other properties in the area the current
design will be in stark contrast with
existing properties in that area the jpc
planning subcommittee totally disputes
the case officers comment I note that
the use of timber and render is not
predominantly used within the street
scene there are some examples within the
street scene and across the wider
conservation area I photos available if
people want to see them on my iPad but
they are just just been showing there
anyway the property's on 47 and 49 these
are simply boarded up to look like
garage doors and not very successfully
either with the regard to the wider
conservation area there are properties
on the high streets which do have timber
cladding however they are a blight on
the high streets and your predecessors
and my bridge jpc for district
predecessors should never have allowed
them to be built in the first place we
should also know this precedent to allow
other carbon costs to be built in this
lovely area I'm sure everyone has
travelled down any High Street have seen
the awful timber clad blocks of flats
and houses at both ends of the High
Street built in the seventies which have
no place in the conservation area of the
High Street the former district
councillor Stephen Thoreau also stated
the use of wood planning has been
reduced but he might be seen as
excessive I thought I would change that
too by the majority of residents in the
area
the design should be reconsidered and
built in red brick as once the original
garage to blend in and complement the
existing street scene
finally the CP re also object on the
basis of not being in keeping with the
street scene in a sensitive location
Thank You councillor any questions I
have just one you say the the you
believe this case should be opposed by
the majority of residents you know where
we've got one letter of objection for
this how do you justify a statement
because we make we talk to the residents
in the area when we have our planning
meetings do you encourage them to write
and make an objection not every time
that's what we feel in that sound job
any other questions councillor Perry
thank you and good evening
can you advise what sort of level of
engagement the applicant has made with
the parish council obviously they've
revised the designs are just just like
to know in terms of the response to your
concerns regarding the club yes they
have redesigned the roof structure which
is better but we still object
wholeheartedly to the timber cladding it
just doesn't fit in to that area at all
and we objected strongly again with him
okay other questions thank his council
thank you very much for your time thank
you thank you our next speaker sorry mr.
Roland Jennings on behalf of the
applicant
welcome so you also have three minutes
if you'd remain seated for any questions
at the end 30 seconds if you like over
to you I should say that I'm Matthew's
father and I'm acting as a messenger so
I'm here to read what he's put down his
response to the the questions from the
parish council the objections raised by
the Parish Council proposals are out of
keeping with the conservation area and
the design is inappropriate
nothing's reply on this is that the
design is in keeping with others on
Prince Harry Road three Doors Down
number 47 is completely wood clad and I
saw that up on the screen number 26 is
rendered and has wood cladding on Prince
Harry Road there are at least seven
different designed houses and all houses
have been built from 1980s onwards
including an office block and Medical
Center there are no listed buildings on
Prince Harry Road a block of flats was
built next door to the proposed well in
three years ago the SDC planning report
noted the characters of the main high
street with its many many historic
properties and that of Prince Harry Road
with its modern properties are
distinctly different however even if you
look at the high street number three
High Street which is also in the
conservation area is extremely prominent
this is rendered and wood clad and
almost identical to our proposal in fact
over 30% of the houses on the high
street are fully rendered even the
Heritage Center itself is completely
rendered
and has wood inlay there are a number of
other houses in Henley with exactly the
same design his response to the second
objection which is there is too much
massing on the site massing is a term in
architecture which refers to the
perception of the general shape and form
as well as size of building the new
house will be set further back from the
road compared to where current buildings
where the 30 second lies this will bring
it in line with the rest of the houses
on Prince Harry Road it will therefore
not to be obtrusive all stand out from
others when traveling down Prince Harry
Road the general shape of the house is
the same as all others on Prince Harry
Road the mass size will be smaller than
that of the block of flats built next
door
which is on a smaller plot number 45
which is four doors down is also
substantially larger than the proposed
new dwelling as are a number of other
houses on the same street mr. Jennings
I'm afraid your time is elapsed and we
have to stop you there is three minutes
any questions for the for mr. Jennings
no mr. Jennings thank you very much for
your time so we go straight to points of
clarification questions you'd like to
ask yes counselor Dixon knowing Prince
Harry Road and the fact that it was
developed relatively short call it
recently in sort of 1986 cetera are we
able to identify for me where the edge
of the conservation area is I can
appreciate the high street is listed the
papers indicate the princess that this
is in the conservation area I'm kind of
surprised that Prince Harry Road is in
the conservation area so if you have a
look at the map you see this pink line
here that that denotes the edge of the
conservation area so it sits on the
eastern boundary of the site so this the
area to the east is not in the
conservation area and then all of the
area to the north and the west is within
the conservation area if I may follow up
chairman would I be right in thinking
that conservation air was possibly drawn
before the development of several
properties along in the rear gardens
back gardens of those properties on High
Street just clarification council atom B
the photos of neighboring property
properties again
okay the points clarification okay
should we go to the debate who would
like to start Thank You chair I note in
the report there's actually a letter of
support from the neighbor which is
always an encouraging thing to see that
actually normally if you're going to get
any objections you actually get an
objection from the neighbor but one
letter of support has been received from
a neighbor also the conservation officer
doesn't appear to have any problems at
all with the design and the application
and therefore on the grounds I cannot
see any material planning reasons to
refuse this application I therefore
propose we go forward to grant thank you
anyone else want to speak in the debate
cat scrum I'm happy to second guess the
party's proposal again very few reasons
to object you'd look at the pictures and
there's that the garage that's been made
into you just go that one that's the one
yeah and you do just wonder so
unbalanced on top it's just support and
secondly proposal thank you all right we
have a proposition in a second and
there's anybody else who would like to
speak in the debate I think I probably
agree with what our two counselors have
said so far actually I can't see this is
gonna cause any demonstrable harm to the
street scene at all really so if we go
to the vote supreme propose the second
of all those in favor
excellent thank you very much in that
case the committee resolves to grant
application reference 18 / 0 2 2 4 4 /
ful
when we go to our final application
sorry item tonight to give the room a
few seconds to clear
okay final application tonight is item
six and found on page 33 of your agendas
this then is application reference D is
CN / 0 0 3 0 4 / 18 and it's for the
land joining church farm court and main
road main street tie so it's for the
erection of 10 dwellings presenting
officer Louise Coleman Louise over to
you thank you - the application is in
relation to the discharge of materials
condition number 3 in connection with
erection of 10 dwellings the application
sites is located on the northern edge of
middle Tysoe village and as identified
by the black dot on the map the
application site outlined in red adjoins
residential development known as Church
farm court to the south and Red Horse
close to the North title Conservation
Area is identified by pink line on the
plan and nearby listed buildings shaded
in red the Cotswolds amb is situated to
the east on the opposite side of Main
Street and a number of public footpaths
are located to the rear and also
opposite the site identified by the
hatch green lines on the plan this is
the approved layout for the ten
dwellings and this is an elevation of
the approved garages which are approved
to be hauntin stone the applicant is
seeking to amend the materials used in
four of the detached garages from
hauntin stone to horizontal timber
cladding and also use brick within the
single garage at the bottom of the
screen the applicant is also seeking to
amend the sill and mental detail on some
of the elevations of the dwellings from
hauntin stone to oak lintels and blue
brick sills
so it's going from there's there's the
blue bricks URLs and this is the Oakland
tools
this is plot two you can see the timber
clad corrosion in the rear the applicant
has provided in an illustration of the
site and timber cladding is proposed on
the four dwellings located in plot two
three four and five and also the single
brick garage is located behind the rear
of plot ten the elevations of all three
plots and the frontage of the sites
which print on to Main Street will
remain with hauntin stone sills and
lintels this is an elevation of plots
seven and eight which is within the site
itself you can see that plot seven is
retained as original and it's just plot
eight which is proposed to change with
the timber lintels in brick cells this
is an elevation of the site with the
cost haunted stone with stone sale this
is a photograph of the proposed blue
brick
which will be used on some of the
properties this is the sample panel for
the single garage and this is the saw an
horizontal timber cladding proposed on
the detached garages now these are some
examples of these types of materials
used within other developments within
the village all the developed dwellings
are within the Heritage field estate
which is on the on the edge of the
village Excel Road also have blue brick
sills and lintels they also have timber
lintels about the garage in here this is
on the site of joining this application
site which is nine church from quartz
which abuts onto the site boundary of
plot one this is the garage for keepers
cottage which is located in the middle
of the village this is a garage at Red
Horse
close again adjoining the site this is
number one read a horse Court that's
what closed which is opposite the cycle
joins a site and this is more historic
building within the middle tyson village
which has a combination of stone and
timber lintels and again another
historic property with timber lintels
the recommendation is to discharge
condition three members in debate I
would just like to you to remember that
this application is only to agree the
materials to be used to build these
houses and garages no other matters are
relevant this evening Thank You Jay
Thank You Louise right first speaker
counselor John Tong from Tyson Parish
Council welcome
welcome so you also have three minutes
tonight if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end and give you a
warning at 30 seconds over to you the
site joins at the conservation area
study was described and he's next to
suite grade 2 listed buildings the home
farm the church and the school and in
fact a grade bomb
Samaras Church we considered his site to
be particularly important it's a leading
road to Tysoe and there's quite
sensitive about the materials the
applicant wanted to change the materials
on went on to the houses to Elias and be
objected and he's changed his mind and
gone back to hauntin the parish council
object to the use of the horizontal
boarding on the four detached two-story
garage office buildings they're detached
and they by reason of their height and
their size and their mass out of keeping
with the surrounding stone buildings
when we think it's inappropriate having
the appearance of for very large tall
garden sheds the first countess
considers that these buildings should be
built in a coarse autumn stone as shown
on the original scheme and be visually
brought to ground by erecting stone
garden walling linking the various stone
buildings on site together the parish
council have no objections the use of
timber boarding on single storey
buildings or those which are attached
and subordinate to the two-story stone
dwellings but they do object to
individually detached two-story garages
perhaps also considers that the use of
three different materials around some of
the windows ie stone jams opening claws
and brick cells to fussy and therefore
Thank You counselor any questions from
the committee
okay council thank you very much thank
you we can move our next speaker mr. our
Chitti Loxton please welcome also have
three minutes same rules apply over to
you say I am from those environments on
a rep setting the application node
applicant on this discharge of condition
three in terms of architectural design
tie so is very diverse and vibrant
village all centered around hauntin so
staying with us a whole man of different
materials starting details around the
village when designing this project our
primary objective was to create schema
integrated into the village we sought
using natural materials and details that
were all found within the village our
proposal is to use Oak timber heads on
some of the windows with blue brick
sails as we've seen earlier those all
found within the village on recent
developments and on old houses within
within the village another one that was
wasn't shown was poor chick clothes
witches would be in the middle toe state
conservation area this is timber lintels
on the windows with ourselves
additionally on back lane there's the
development which incorporates red brick
heads and blue brick sails on some of
the houses and on other houses we're in
the same development there are some were
timber heads and blue bricks hills even
within the immediate context of our site
as we've seen all their materials that
we are proposing to use are relevant and
within context around the village as
i've said there are all manner of
materials there timber heads with
tarsals and especially around the
village shop area I would dispute the
patch counselors claimed that the use of
three materials around each window is
fast
and not characteristic of local design
and the council's conservation officer
on their report also identified there
was within keeping with the village the
character of the village is derived from
its eclectic use of materials and
details rather than homogeneous design
on the use of sawn timber bordering on
garages as we've seen it is found within
the immediate context of the site on the
developments on either side and
elsewhere within the village and it is
encouraged within the village design
statement written by the Parish Council
I think on this basis when they say that
all other structures out there these
departments or garage is not built using
natural stone should be constructed
using new or acclaimed handmade facing
bricks red orange in color or large
feather or wainy and to wainy edged
timber cladding exactly what we are
proposing to use as a material for this
reason I believe their gesture is unjust
at 30 seconds when the non-material mine
amendment was first submitted in March
of last year our case officers said they
wanted the garage boarding to be left as
natural timber and not stained precisely
what we are doing now I felt my account
of all this information and the case
officers report the conservation
officers findings and all other
information submitted that condition
free of applications should be
discharged thank you thank you very much
questions starting this account's
Richard thank you
was it your firm that originally applied
for permission or have you acquired the
permission its approval the there was
permission on the lands for my firm
bought it and then it was reapplied for
about in 2016 to build ten houses on
okay and the reason I ask that is
clearly you've made a commitment to
build in certain materials when you
first applied for and you've got your
permission it's quite significant change
particularly in relation to the garages
and their styling and design why is
there such a significant change now the
change was determined but I wanted to
use a sparkle prime oak
who have fill colleges all over the
stratford district council area or
precinct and we thought that they would
be more keeping more bond like their
more rural than i would say so just so
I'm clear having made the commitment to
create stone garages you've then chosen
an oak provider to provide those stone
carriages and that's why we're changing
is that right is that right yes that is
correct
so we we had the opportunity to change
because of the discharge of conditions
has taken so long and so we decided to
change at that point to create something
that would be we wanted something softer
than the hauntin stone it's quite harsh
there's a lot of it in the development
over 85% of the materials being used on
site it's London stone so we wanted
something to be incorporated into it and
softened their parents of the whole
development okay councillor Crump well
the change in materials is it brought
about by you know you said about softer
softer appearance at Accenture or was it
brought about and due to cost savings
basically have you you know it's the
real basis behind this are you doing it
for the appearance and how it works I
think I'm gonna come in there I mean
you're welcome to answer if you want but
I'm not sure it's a relevant question to
planning I'm concerned he'd come forward
with an application that was approved
with with stone which is material of a
higher quality okay I changed the
question sorry can you give us
reassurance that the quality of the
materials that you're using or want to
use will be of a similar nature or
compared to the previous application
what's the difference in quality
basically so there isn't really any
difference in
it's more about aesthetics than the
quality of the materials they're all
natural materials and you know I say
have you ever seen a pilot building or a
primate garage yeah you know they're
high quality buildings they haven't like
a lot of sense gravitas they have their
big like thick timber posts and that
that's what we want to put there just
from a visual point of view it will look
better like trust me they're not cheap
buildings and it's not going to look
like a cheap garden shed which is what
essentially the plants that said my
question Thank You Chancellor Perry than
cancer
thank you hello good evening I just
wonder whether you can advise what sort
of level of engagement you've had with
the parish council over this change of
direction in terms of design materials
we speaking with cancer fielding about
it and we have the Parish Council
meeting in Council Dixon each other I
think you mentioned wavy oak wavy edge
yeah I'm not sure that there was an
example shown on the screen there
because that to my mind I think it said
softwood and it was cladding I said
feather edge planning that is the
cleanest proposed to be used on the
outside of the house but that of the
couch but that is not so where it says
the power chance to say they would like
large beverage or way me timbers
planning and that is separation cladding
I thought you mentioned that you having
oak wavy edge
big fun yeah okay
yes cancer Adam regarding the aesthetic
of the timber cladding for soft wood how
would that need to be treated to be
remain weather tight will that age
naturally will that need treating and
will that then tie into the aesthetic of
similar buildings in the village all
that depend on how they treated so we
weren't planning to say nor treat them
as per our case offices recommendations
in March of last year so they were aged
naturally and be in keeping with the
village there are further questions if
if the committee will minded to ask for
them to be stained or treated in a
particular colour would that be
something you would be amenable to yep
all right thank you
other questions thank you very much for
your time very much right we now move to
our final speaker councillor fielding
board member
over to you before you is an example
frustration I arranged a meeting with
the planning officer in John Tong to
agree the materials and the color and I
would like the question to the planning
officer whether that is the timber that
we discussed and agreed we also
discussed the plan showing that stone
had been agreed in the planning meeting
of the 26th of 2016
before my election the plans definitely
showed stone knock timber which is the
reason for this hearing and this was
confirmed by the planning officer this
results around the problems of the
developer being allowed to get away with
what he wants rather than conforming to
what has been agreed by a planning
committee and the officer in my in the
opinion of the parish council SDC is not
taken to concerns over planning decision
seriously I'm in full support of the
parish council and he must be borne in
mind the neighboring development on the
north side is also cause of great deal
of upset and anger within the village
the developer has been allowed to start
work before construction management
plans have been signed off and agreed
enforcement's appears unwilling to take
action to stop
of the commencement of work I've had to
deal with two schemes that have got
underway without paperwork being
completed and the planning officer
rushing to catch up in the two cases
I've got the officer to visit the site
to hear the frustrations of the parish
council and I hope the committee will
understand the parish is concerned and
also the support we need from SDC
winning we represent our ward we must be
forthcoming and counseling yes questions
councillor Richards clearly we can't
make a decision on any enforcement
action that might be pending or is
currently undergoing however the
impression you've just given me is that
there is enforcement action taken on
this site for these changes am i
misunderstanding that or are you telling
me that this is technically a
retrospective application therefore it's
not you know buying stuff is irrelevant
they actually start so it's not
retrospective okay that's helpful from a
planning perspective obviously we need
to have very sound planning reasons to
refuse this application if we were
minded to do so you haven't I didn't
fully grasp what you're planning reasons
were if you could really late them for
me that would be very helpful
deals with comment which one deals with
sensitivity matters to do with I think
it's either nine or five I can't
remember ultimately can take into
consideration was just just to reiterate
and so I'm absolutely clear it's the
sensitivity in the design you are most
concerned about thank you thank you any
further questions for the ward member
that case counsel fielding thank you
right points clarification we just just
clarify is this a retrospective
application first of all no thank you
just wanted that confirmed any other
points of clarification counts the Perry
Thank You chair I just would seek some
clarification from the officers on CS
nine point three point eight four where
it states it involves the involvement of
the local residents and communities in
the design of development and it is
important that engagement and local
communities both early on in the design
process and meaningful so that local
communities have real opportunities to
influence the outcome of the design
process can you just confirm what wait
we should be giving to that point of the
core strategy place
two seconds
sorry about not sure if I understood the
question counselor Perry was referring
to paragraph three point eight point
four in the core strategy which is
supporting text which explains how the
design process should go on as we heard
from the developer
there has been engagement with the
Parish Council and we're also at a
position where there's a difference of
opinion between the developer and the
Parish Council you have a recommendation
from your officers who consider that the
put in front of you is acceptable and
that's based effectively on the wording
of the policy and it's the wording of
the policy that's critical and the
wording of the policy invites you to
make a planning judgment your officers
have made that planning judgement and I
think paragraph two is probably the
critical one
the proposals including layout and
orientation will be sensitive to the
setting existing built form neighboring
uses landscape character etc then we're
not going to the second power of the
second sentence proposals will reflect
the context of the locality ensuring a
continuity of key design features it's
the critical phrase Thank You councillor
Richard thanks I'm just I'm getting my
head the number of garages that are
changing you've said for two plots two
three four and five are changing from
Horton stone to timber clad and then
there is a further garage single big
area to plot ten is going to be red
brick is that correct plot - that
doesn't change plot - has a detached
garage that's changing plot three
detached garage which is changing four
and five also have the detached garages
but six that stays the same seven and
eight
I have the garages as far as I can
recall and and nine just has parking at
the rear in its ten that has the garage
there so so so again to get it right in
my head while I'm deliberating this well
you say half but seven and eight and
nine don't even have garages so of the
seven that do five of them are changing
can I ask the officers the the examples
that we've shown in the photographs
where oak cladding or cladding has been
used are all of those examples Oak wavy
board cladding as opposed to what I
think is proposed here soft wavy edge
boarding but yeah councilor Richards and
other things just struck me that this is
to my boy thinking this is quite
significant change in the design layer
of the overall development why why is
that scope for this to be changed under
a discharge of a condition and not
requiring a full very application to be
submitted I think Jeff I'd approach that
question from the other direction the
planning permission was granted with a
condition requiring materials to be
agreed the expectation was that the
whole development will be built in in
hauntin stone that's not what's come
forward as part of this discharge of
conditions and what we have to consider
is whether this is acceptable in its own
right not
why it's changed from a previous
material it's this material is this
material appropriate so you just go back
on that I obviously don't have the
benefit of seeing the original
application the can there was no
condition to say that these garages will
be on stone it was a we might do a
norton stone but we'll agree this stuff
how we're going to do afterwards
is that correct so what you're telling
me now yes the expectation was when
permission was granted that they would
be built in hauntin stone yes but it was
an expectation it wasn't a requirement
and even if it had been a requirement
sure we can always reconsider those
requirements subject to an application
of course I think that's where I was
getting to you we can of course we
consider it under a very when you're not
doing that here and I think your
experiment and explanation now has
explained to me why we're not
considering it as a very why we're
saying as a condition right so I
appreciate your help thank you okay
council field he has indicated he'd like
to come back in Council I'll allow it
but it's got to be a clarification of a
point of fact and I will have to invite
the applicant back up as well in spirit
of fairness if you want to in a second
sir not just yet go for it
two points of fact one is that the
original plans that was shown at the
planning application showed stone the
second point is that since February
since the the change of use of the
buildings
I don't record a discussing it I don't
recall them coming back to the parish
council which I regularly attend and so
I think that there is lack of
consultation with the parish
in terms of what counts the fielding has
just mentioned those plans that he would
have seen originally would have been
indicative plans would they not yes
Jared we've established the plans
indicated an expectation that hauntin
stone would be used but members did not
so did he go to committee members did
not require the hauntin stone and we put
the normal materials condition on which
is why we're here today
discharging that condition so the every
stage came back to planning and with the
parish council would have been informed
yes okay Kathie Lee I'll have to ask you
to retire from the committee at this
point again you're welcome to you come
back sorry I should say to the applicant
at this point you're welcome to speak if
you want it's your choice it's anything
you'd like to say in response to that
additional question
any questions no you happy okay
back two points of clarification
councillor Richards so that was
obviously raising the point of
clarification in in terms of how the
original conditions were put i've seen
many times and i'm pretty sure most
developments have the condition built
out in accordance with submitted plans
clearly from what what i've just picked
up there this that there were submitted
plans and they showed horton stone how
do we deal with this
I mean clearly we're looking at a
discharge condition but one condition
one says one thing one says another
there's a conflict and I'm concerned
that a very procedural issue could come
back and cause us a problem perhaps we
want to seek legal advice what do you
think I'm not really seeing the problem
that councillor Richard says approved
plans at a high level of information and
we drill into that high level of
information through the conditions that
we impose and through the submission on
those conditions this application is
let's be absolutely Frank about this
unique in the parish council was heavily
involved in the selection of materials
at the time the application was
originally going through and we had
negotiations with the applicant and that
is why he showed hauntin stone at that
time but we did not condition it to
allow flexibility to allow later
agreement table materials because that
is our normal practice so there was no
departure from normal practice that the
applicant has now come forward with
timber cladding rather than hauntin
it's not something that that officers
invited or expected but it's something
that we're dealing with it's perfectly
legitimate for the applicant to make
that request and it's perfectly
legitimate for us to consider whether
actually in planning terms those amended
materials are acceptable or not I hope
yeah I I don't think I'm debating
whether or not it's appropriate for an
applicant to make these submissions I
absolutely accept that and my concern is
a procedural one or whether it shouldn't
be a very over a discharge I'm clearly
you're here to give us guidance it's
here under a discharge anyway I can only
base my decision making now on what
you're telling me and that is a matter
of fact and law so that is the case okay
points of clarification debate look I'm
entirely unhappy about the submission
I'm not buying developers come forward
to say actually it's going to look nicer
if we do it this way at the end of the
day a developer is whilst providing an
appropriate development also looking at
their bottom line now that is not a
planning reason or plan a consideration
in planning terms so once i'm entirely
unhappy with it i can't find a planning
reason to prevent this from happening
and i don't think i'll be alone in
saying i'm unhappy with it i'm sure
there'll be other people around the
table that in a similar position and
certainly that has been expressed by our
district counselor and the parish
council but we have to have a planning
reason and i can't find one so unless
someone else can i propose that we do go
with it
as recommendation and proof okay anybody
helps counselor Perry I have to say
counselor rich has basically took the
words out of my mouth I have terrific
sympathy with the parish council on this
application because they have gone
beyond the usual realms to really make
sure that this particular is quite a
landmark site in theis so actually no
Tice thing pretty well to make sure that
they actually had a development that
really sat really well particularly in
view of its close proximity to read
halls close and they've they've they've
gone to huge lengths to make sure that
they had the Horton stone throughout and
then it's like coming through the back
door and we'll put put this on and it's
and I am like cats and Rich's I cannot
find a serious play material planning
reason to reject this but I am very
unhappy about it and I think it's very
sad that when a Parish Council is so
passionate about making sure they get
all the right materials in the village
which has a grating and theis over all
places because you've got lower Tysoe
middle ty so an appetizer and it's like
a communication of a community community
link of three different villages and I
just think it's very sad but we are
forced I'm afraid with our arms tied
behind our backs and I have no
alternative but to Second Council Rich's
proposal Thank You counselor come yeah
I'm saying in my line of work hard to
have too crazy certainty but we seem to
have a lot of uncertainty or we did have
uncertainty until we had the debate and
cancer Richards interrogated dial very
well by the way cancer it is I've got me
a problem
thank you but I think we need to learn
from this and make sure that when we
have something come forward like this
again with our materials you could say
it's a material consideration sorry
about that
but I think we need to make sure this
doesn't happen again
we've had we've had the Paras going
forward with their views quite rightly
so we need to make sure if we do make
any ambiguity uncertainty is removed
from the process I know we have some
areas of discretion and some decisions
are left to that to plan and chair and
consultation offices but I think there
is a learning point from this
application and hopefully we can turn
that forward as well just briefly like
to lend support to that argument and say
this does seem to be a show of bad faith
between the parish council in the
developer and that has been reinforced
by passionate statements by the parish
council and the ward member so if I
would like to lend my support in
investigations what can be done in the
future to defer the clarification on
these matters okay I'll just add my
thoughts well then things we're
finishing up here I think you're right I
think this would have been much better
had the parish council pin all the
you're right this is this application
has been going around for a very long
time I mean I think I've seen this at
this committee for what three times at
least so it's been back and forth of us
so many times and it's such a shame to
see the thoughts and the wishes of the
parish council have been ignored from an
aesthetic point of view I've got to
admire I actually quite like the chamber
to be honest with you but that's just me
being totally honest and just to annoy
everybody but I quite like it but but
you're right we should where we can we
should and yeah there you go but beauty
is in the eye of the beholder I quite
like it but there we go
but when you do have an agreement when
you are consulting with a parish council
I think that you know you're it's
required of you you're responsible to
keep to that that's what you've agreed a
deal's a deal there we are
it's proposed is seconded unless anybody
else wants to speak should we go to the
vote and all those in favor okay that
case the committee resolves to grant
application reference di s CN / 0 0 3 4
0 3 o 4 / 1 8 that is our final
application tonight we do have urgent
business and that is for me to ask the
committee are we all content to continue
with the start time of 6:15 for this
committee in future show of hands
everyone happy with 6:15 unless you want
to say otherwise
Garth I was just gonna say the only
reason we carried it over from the last
meeting is because we wanted to make
sure yes thank you for sharing what's
meeting anyway thank you very much
everybody meeting closed